[Music]
on this Thursday night cruel summer the
Urgent new warnings about
record-shattering Heat and the
ramifications of rising ocean
temperatures the Eda of global warming
has ended here at Global boiling has
arrived
being proactive the four wildfires erupt
the future of our fire environment is
going to be
difficult how artificial intelligence
could be a critical tool paying for
premium Health Care the Canadian Clinic
where patients can jump the queue for a
cost
and caught on camera then I was like
okay let's take a few shots
prize-winning photos focused on climate
change
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us the
warning signs are everywhere for weeks
millions of people have been enduring
scorching temperatures and now the World
Meteorological organization says July is
on track to be the Earth's warmest
months on record we've been watching it
happen searing heat raging wildfires
July's Heat Wave has been off the charts
on three continents North America Europe
and Asia it follows the hottest June on
record and today the head of the United
Nations used Stark language to try to
shock people and governments into action
humans are to blame all this is entirely
consistent with predictions and repeated
warnings
the only surprise is the speed of the
change climate change is here it is
terrifying and it is just the beginning
humanity is on the hot seat Gutierrez
says the air he says is unbreathable the
heat unbearable and the level of fossil
fuel profits and climate inaction is
unacceptable the data is from the
European Union's Copernicus climate
change service and the World
Meteorological organization it shows the
first 23 days of July have been the
hottest since records began on July 6
the hottest day the global average
temperature was 17.23 degrees Celsius
and the eight warmest years on the books
are the past eight
today the U.S president announced new
steps to help Americans face the
existential threat of climate change as
the president called it the plans
include shielding workers from high
temperatures improving weather
forecasting and better access to
drinking water measures critics say are
too modest President Biden today noted
even the ocean off Florida is hotter
than ever
ocean temperatures near Miami are like
sitting in a hot tub they just topped
100 degrees 100 degrees and they're
hitting record highs around the world
100 degrees Fahrenheit is almost 38
degrees Celsius what's happening to the
world's oceans is being closely watched
there's evidence of vital ocean current
that carries warm water from the tropics
to the North Atlantic could collapse and
it could happen quickly Eric Sorensen
explains why and what that could mean
the major currents in the Atlantic Ocean
move billions of tons of warm water
North and cold water South a powerful
yet delicate exchange that balances the
earth's climate but it could all
collapse within years according to a new
study unlike gradual global warming
slowing or stopping the Atlantic's
circulating currents could make parts of
the northern hemisphere dramatically
colder it's happened before says the
study's author the overturning
circulation can be in an on state which
is where we're in now and an off state
which was what happened in the in
glacial times
12 000 years ago you recall what you
said about how polar melting might
disrupt the North Atlantic current
scientists say it wouldn't be like the
Hollywood film where cities froze
overnight but changes could happen
within a very few years if this is going
to happen this is a
complete change of climate the warm
Waters in and around the Gulf of Mexico
stream North and East toward Europe a
colossal heat pump it's one reason
northern Europe is warmer than Northern
Canada the Gulf Stream system though is
part of the global conveyor belt that
Cycles warm and cold water currents
around the planet among the most
powerful forces on Earth but the
overturning circulation in the Atlantic
is being disrupted by global warming and
by fresh water rapidly melting in the
Arctic affecting salinity and density
that could slow or even stop the
delicate balance in these currents that
Tipping Point disrupting the Gulf Stream
would be felt everywhere but especially
in Europe where temperatures could
plunge several degrees
northern Europe could see longer and
colder Winters up to 10 degrees colder
but the bigger impact may be in
sun-baked tropical regions where the
Earth's heat would stay and build
threatening billions unable to mitigate
the impacts from a more Sudden Change in
the climate they're going to have a
really big impact on in terms of farming
agriculture food supply water supply
some of those regions are really
struggling with that already David
thornale says it's too early to draw
conclusions because other studies
suggest a less than 10 percent
probability that a Tipping Point will
collapse the Atlantic currents in this
Century still he adds that's a 10 chance
of something catastrophic Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
intense wildfires this summer are adding
to already dangerous levels of
greenhouse gas emissions according to
data published by the UN and the eu's
top climate agencies smoke from
wildfires in Canada this year has caused
the highest emissions ever recorded in
this country and there's little relief
there are extreme heat and air quality
warnings across Canada temperatures are
expected to hit 40 degrees in Toronto
tomorrow there are more than 800 fires
burning across the country and in BC
alone there are 400 active wildfires
[Applause]
three hikers in BC found out how fast
moving those fires can be they were
rescued by this helicopter when a fire
cut off access to the trail leading back
to their car the chopper operated by a
local tour operator spotted the hikers
while on patrol it had been contracted
to help during the province's
unprecedented Wildfire season this fire
started on Monday and has already grown
to more than 10 square kilometers
the number of wildfires igniting this
season is forcing governments First
Responders and scientists to adapt and
find new strategies and that includes
embracing new technology tonight turia
isri looks at the potential artificial
intelligence offers
if AI predicts traffic patterns
scientists say it should be able to
predict wildfires too having the
capacity to to Really capitalize on the
future of technology is kind of
essential this season Flames have
already burned four times more land than
average they've claimed lives displaced
thousands and reduced air quality for
Millions more and with a warming Planet
things are only expected to get worse
here we can see a sharp increase Hussein
banak dhari teaches engineering at the
University of Ottawa he's working with a
team of researchers in Hawaii to predict
wildfires on the islands AI is like a
brain you know we need to feed AI by the
the different types of experiences
things like satellite imagery weather
data and human activity
he's inputting huge swaths of
information into a computer to interpret
all that data and search for patterns
because right now much of it sits in
silos the problem of wildfire can be
solved completely by the help of AI it's
all part of an artificial intelligence
Revolution tech companies around the
world are using AI for just about
anything whether it's answering
questions Conjuring up images or
detecting the next disaster this is the
new version that we are making Joe Lopez
runs a Brazilian company which uses
sensors to monitor the fire risk in
forests he's in discussions with
provinces here in Canada all the
predictions are made by intelligence by
artificial intelligence right because uh
when we collect a lot of data you need
to use this data smartly
while scientists say there are
limitations to AI they insist Canada
needs to be using all tools at its
disposal
fight has changed we got a change with
it
changing the strategy to better respond
to a changing climate Toria esri Global
News Ottawa
new charges have been added to the
indictment against former U.S president
Donald Trump the charges allege Trump
was part of a scheme to delete
surveillance video related to the
mishandling and concealment of
classified documents seized from his
Mar-A-Lago Resort and a third person has
been indicted a man identified as a
property manager at Mar-A-Lago who is
alleged to have told another employee
that the boss wanted the server deleted
it's alleged the plan was to foil
investigators probing the removal of the
documents from the White House Trump has
pleaded not guilty in a trial has been
set for May of 2024.
prime minister Justin Trudeau is in
Newfoundland today a day after he
overhauled his front bench it was his
biggest cabinet Shuffle since coming to
power assigning 23 cabinet ministers new
roles and adding seven rookies to the
team it is a move liberals have called
an economic revamp as Mackenzie gray
reports the sweeping overhaul could
present challenges for the Prime
Minister when Parliament returns in
September
Justin Trudeau's visit to Newfoundland
felt like a campaign stop I've built a
cabinet that is going to be positioned
to grow and continue to build great
opportunities for Canadians but that
cabinet construction is short one of his
previous top ministers David lemetti out
at Justice and from cabinet completely
he has led on important files around
Justice and Reconciliation
a senior government Source said the
biggest reason lametti was dumped I'm
not sure LMP needed to go to get new
tourism Minister sir Roya Martinez
Ferrera in the cabinet the prime
minister's office also wasn't happy with
the speed of lametti's judicial
appointments and believes his
replacement or referrani is better
suited to handle upcoming legislation
around online harms and crime in cities
much of the despite getting the boot
well Medi is willing to stay on as a
backbencher I intend to run in the next
election whenever it may be he posted on
Facebook making him one of three former
ministers still in caucus that could
cause a headache for Justin Trudeau
ex-ministers if they aren't given
another assignment like chair of a
parliamentary committee or ahead of some
sort of exercise or role in the campaign
uh you know or sort of loose free agents
within the political system is this the
worst it's ever been the assignment for
Christian Freeland lead the charge on
sharpening the Liberals economic message
to help her execute on that former
Defense Minister Anita Anand has been
brought in as the new treasury board
president and despite getting a lower
profile rule the Oakville MP is still
viewed as a top performer by pmo Onan
had made it known she wouldn't mind an
economically focused portfolio a job
that will allow her to be more visible
domestically to take on Pierre polyev's
populist and popular economic message
the notion of the government having a
new strategy is not going to come from
just the rearrangement of folks it's
going to come from whether or not they
have a new agenda it's no surprise to
see Trudeau in Freeland in Atlanta
Canada it's the only part of the country
they're still ahead of the conservatives
Donna but even then it's only by one
point
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa tonight thanks
there's a new battle Brewing between
public and private Health Care this one
in Alberta a Calgary Clinic is offering
memberships to patients starting next
month they'll cost thousands of dollars
and promise to deliver what the clinic
calls proactive Health Care Services
Health Canada is pushing back but with
six and a half million Canadians now
estimated to be without a family doctor
there are calls for governments to do
more Heather urich's West reports
patients of this Calgary Medical Clinic
May soon have to pay a premium for
timely access to care in a recent letter
the MARTA Loop Medical Center told its
patients we acknowledge that accessing
efficient Health Care has been a
persistent challenge to address these
challenges starting August 1st we will
be offering a membership-based medical
service for twenty two hundred dollars a
year for individuals or 4 800 for
families the membership promises reduced
wait times
clinics can charge for services not
insured under Canada's Health act but
paying to jump the queue for insured
services like a doctor's visit Health
Canada says that goes against federal
law we can't just stop with the question
of you know these fees are are being
paid and does it comply with the Canada
Health act we have to go further and
actually ask why are these fees being
charged post-pandemic Family Physicians
are packing up practices like never
before leaving 22 percent of Canadians
without a doctor of their own some of
that does relate to how much money
people are making as a family doctor
doing regular Family Practice compared
to how much money they would be making
doing other things with that same degree
and qualifications it's why British
Columbia recently changed how Physicians
are paid instead of receiving a fee per
visit they're now compensated for a
range of other duties as well well
people talk about the the equality of
some being able to pay to have greater
service a greater inequality would be
for people to lose their family doctor
because they work in this place where
there are inflationary pressures and the
practice has to close for the MARTA Loop
Medical Center the membership fee
program isn't likely to stick around the
premier directed Alberta Health to
investigate and health Canada says
Alberta risks losing Federal transfer
payments if they don't step in Heather
your ex West Global News Calgary
the Russian president meets African
leaders coming out the promise Putin
made and what he says can replace
Ukrainian grain exports
there's unrest and uncertainty in the
West African country of Niger after its
president was removed in a coup
supporters of the plot targeted the
ruling party's headquarters today the
military is now supporting members of
the presidential guard who led
Wednesday's coup and detained president
Muhammad bazoom coup leaders went on TV
accusing him of poor governance and
deteriorating National Security bazoom
was a key Western Ally in the fight
against islamist militancy in West
Africa
I spoke with President bazoom earlier
this morning and made clear that the
United States resolutely supports him as
the democratically elected President of
Niger
we call for his immediate release
on Twitter bazoom remained defiant
saying the hard one achievements will be
safeguarded all Nigerians who love
democracy and freedom will see to it
when he came to office in 2021 it was
the country's first Democratic transfer
of power
at the Russia Africa Summit in St
Petersburg today Africa's dependence on
food imports was front and center with a
warning the continent's food security is
at stake last week Russian President
Vladimir Putin pulled out of a deal it
allowed exports of grain and oil seeds
from Ukraine today he promised months of
free grain deliveries to six African
nations Crystal gomancing looks at the
impact of Russia's growing influence in
Africa
Vladimir Putin is embracing friends from
the African continent and wooing those
who are lukewarm to the Russian
president
saying he's sincerely interested in
further deepening multifaceted trade his
biggest carrot to drum up more business
an offer of up to 50 000 tons of free
grain for at least six African nations
the president of Zimbabwe said his
country has enough grain but expressed
gratitude for fertilizer donations this
gesture is just
apprenticeship of the Russian Federation
to the people of Zimbabwe Africa is
split on Russia and its full invasion of
Ukraine in March of 2022 during a U.N
vote on a resolution whether to denounce
and demand Russia withdraw 28 African
nations voted in favor of the motion 17
abstained aged in caste ballots and one
Eritrea voted against it it's well
documented that yevgeny pregosian's
mercenary group Wagner is active in
several African nations including Mali
and Burkina Faso after seizing power in
the second coup of 2022 the now interim
president of Burkina Faso is one of the
kremlin's 49 invited guests despite his
own coup attempt pagosian is pictured
here in Saint Petersburg with a man
wearing the multi-colored lanyard
associated with the Russian African
Summit
Putin bragged to Summit attendees that
Russian Farmers would have a record
Harvest and can replace Ukrainian grain
exports it comes as he continues to
strike Odessa destroying agricultural
infrastructure around the port
a solution to the Russian Ukrainian
crisis is needed says the chair of the
African union he warned the partnership
with Russia is at stake as is food
security for Millions
Crystal gomancing Global News London
severe storm ahead the devastation as a
typhoon batters the Philippines
[Music]
at least 20 people are dead after a
passenger boat capsized near the
Philippine Capital Manila 40 people on
board were rescued and the Coast Guard
says they're still searching for
survivors the ship sank in strong winds
from a typhoon which also caused schools
and businesses to close and grounded
flights the severe storm is expected to
make landfall on China's southeast coast
and off the coast of the Netherlands a
cargo ship packed with nearly 3 000
Vehicles is still burning two days after
Flames first broke out one crew member
died a number of others were injured
jumping 30 meters overboard to escape
the Dutch Coast Guard says the situation
is stable now and the cause of the fire
is being investigated
the power of Photography next reflecting
on Humanity's relationship with nature
[Music]
the impact of climate change is all
around us yet it's so all encompassing
it can be hard to grasp Sometimes the
best way is to show pictures nithu
Garcia takes us through the winners of
an international competition aimed at
rewarding photographers who put their
creativity to good use
a grieving whale off the coast of Spain
carrying her dead calf and these
villagers of all ages crowding to fill
their buckets from a 20 000 liter water
tanker in India it takes two hours to
fill but gets emptied within seven
minutes we want a picture that give a
message we don't want just a beautiful
picture these are the award-winning
images from an international
environmental photography prize focused
on raising public awareness about the
impacts of climate change about 10 000
images were submitted by more than 2 000
photographers from around the world all
the countries have to move to reduce the
uh
the global warming and the first I was
shooting video
um and then I was like okay let's take a
few shots took a few shots Canadian
photographer Dustin patar didn't know it
then but while he was shooting this
Drone footage of a Nunavut dog team in
June of 2022 he would capture something
so meaningful it beat out thousands of
entries you can
you know someone's taking
earlier and that affects you know the
Run he says the image depicts the loss
of Arctic sea ice as temperatures rise
the snow covering the ice melts exposing
pools of water revealing the turquoise
blue ice beneath it and looking at it
you can feel the danger
the grand prize winning photo also tells
a story of struggle a panicked elephant
in central Africa hit by a train the
tracks cross through the animal's path
in a national park this elephant was so
badly injured it was euthanized the
railway which is the big problem who
cuts the the movement of the wildlife
like the other animals in each of these
powerful images this one elephant
represents his entire species in the
grip of an uncertain future with a
message of Hope for a more positive
human impact
Global News
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is Nippon Saskatchewan we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching nitu will be here at
the anchor desk tomorrow and I'll see
you again on Monday bye-bye
[Music]
thank you